[Music]
imagine there was a way to never feel
tired again
this is not one of them it doesn't
matter if your sleep sucks or you sleep
great but you feel tired throughout the
day I will guarantee that you will take
away something from this video that will
make a measurable difference in how you
feel I've tried everything because for
the last seven years I've been fighting
a battle against my body
a body is not doing what it's supposed
to do I've tried everything
all right stop let me summarize this
entire video for you the biggest reason
why you're tired and low energy is
because the solution is so simple that
you will roll your eyes skip those parts
of the video and not learn from my seven
years of mistakes I've warned you you'll
see my plan I will start with the things
I know the basics which are going for
morning walks staying hydrated
exercising intermittent fasting getting
lots of sunlight and then winding down
an hour before bed it's almost 8pm again
working a little late just want to get a
few more things done and yes I'm gonna
wind down eventually better late than
never
all right I think this was good 77. this
is a score out of 100 from the most
accurate sleep tracking device the aura
ring and I thought this was great until
I realized this was only the beginning
my sleep score an hour and a half of REM
sleep almost three hours deep sleep and
a great resting heart rate oh nice Leon
this is mine from last night
I can't believe it over two hours of REM
sleep three and a half hours of deep
sleep not a single wake up almost nine
hours of Total Sleep is everything all
right Leon it's impressive
the new goal was clear beat Kyle and get
my sleep score into the 90s but that was
going to take work Kyla's a sleep coach
and an expert on recovery he spent years
figuring out how to get better energy
and knows things that most people don't
and if I wanted to beat him I was really
gonna have to level up it's almost 11AM
and I haven't gone outside yet to get
some sunlight good movement in walk
today's routine is not looking too good
so far as you may have seen in previous
videos I haven't had the best
relationship when it comes to self-care
I would always see self-care as
something that is a bit of a waste of
time but since the brain training that
my friend RAF and I did in Sedona I've
gotten so much more aware of how I'm
mistreating myself logically I knew it's
important to recharge and recover but
emotionally I've always felt like
self-care is something for people that
are entitled and just spoiled but it's
time to change that what does it really
feel like to have great energy today has
been a good day so far tons of habits
and sticks to the routine tomorrow
morning will I have better sleep than
Kyle I think you could do it his is like
in the 90s dude I've never reached that
I feel like if you have a wind down
routine you would hit 90s Kyle already
started his four hour sleep routine I'm
just here to beat you I'm gonna have
better sleep scores than you you can
will that into existence as much as you
want it's just never gonna happen
are you not entertained
what's your sleep core 93
.
if I hadn't woken up to take a piss
this could have been in the 90s and I
could have rubbed it in Kyle's face this
is not a game anymore these guys have
declared war welcome to competitive
sleeping Kyle gives me no other choice
time to start working out consistently
in the mornings and get that sleep up
75 sleep School ice bath and sauna day
now Kyle doesn't have access to these
things so I'm going to crush him
76.
I want to try winding down for an hour
like Kyle look who's come to wind down
the sleep Daddy is here what are you
doing I stopped eating at six o'clock I
stopped eating at five o'clock and then
I'm gonna take Magtech from natural
Stacks this is the best form of
magnesium use my code not Leon's code
jokes aside I've linked all Sleep
Products Kyle and I used in the
description and we also recorded a
podcast compiling all the sleep tips
75 a bunch of wake UPS I'm hitting a bit
of a plateau here at 75. so today I'm
gonna do a bit of a digital detox
because I think that's one of the
reasons why people have low energy
they're just over stimulate it
how do I stop waking up during the night
to me if you're waking up between two
and four and it's like I'm up that's
blood sugar I got this continuous
glucose monitor which is going to help
me keep an eye on my blood sugar because
that may be the reason why I keep waking
up during the night what should I do now
go for a morning walk we'll set your
blood sugar for the rest of the day I'll
do that right now I'll make you proud
then I'll beat you with your scores
hey Leon did you go for your walk yet
75 sleep
I think I'm doing everything right but I
feel like something's still missing for
this video we also partnered up with
let'sgetchecked.com which is a side for
getting Health tests done online they
send you the test kit you do the sample
yourself and then it just gets picked up
you can do everything right and still
feel off because something in your body
is out of whack so I took a
micronutrient test a thyroid test or
what I think is most important for men a
testosterone test because if something's
wrong there you're going to want to know
so you can fix it and my results were
interesting looks all great except for
this one thing cortisol
is high so check out let's get checked
with the link below or use the code
leon25 at checkout for 25 off trust me
the sooner you know the better your boys
got healthy testosterone High cortisol
okay that makes sense what do you mean
money blocks are going to be really
important for you I don't want to be
completely negative about this I mean
sleep school was 75. that's not bad for
all the things that I did yeah
I think it was it was bad yeah right
because like mine was like 95. this
just do anything yeah I'm happy to spend
all day to optimize my sleep so you said
this has been happening for seven years
what happened right before that I think
it started when I was building my first
business I was just forced to leave
Australia after I had met my ex
ex-girlfriend and I was back in Germany
I was miserable and those were the times
where I would wake up in the middle of
the night heart racing and just like
unable to sleep like what did you tell
yourself about what was going on in that
season of your life in my mind if I
don't build that business if I don't
achieve these things I'll never be happy
yeah maybe there's something in there
78 all right I think we're getting
somewhere how'd you sleep I was up again
for an hour and a half at night yeah
dude I fell asleep like tonight I may
just do what Riker suggested my other
roommate just visualizing myself
sleeping through the night and just
telling my body hey this is how it's
gonna go I I think it could work now
that you're getting consistent like 75s
and I'll just bump that up by like Five
Points dude if I get a consistent 80s
holy like this is these are the best
sleep scores I usually get that's
literally like a bad night so there's so
much room to grow take this as far as
you want it can get pretty crazy
ah
I was up until 1am couldn't fall asleep
I was out until 10 pm for dinner with
friends it's past my eating Window Guys
and now I paid the price eating late
last night caused my glucose to spike to
131 so I had trouble falling asleep now
what does a ring of power say 65 sleep
I'm an idiots no it's fine
just follow the protocol today
you'll recover so in German we have this
term called The Devil's cycle which
basically means that the worse things
get the worse they get ah one of these
days where I get to be
gentle with myself for being a
idiot when you get bad sleep you have
less energy to work out you also crave
bad food and that means you sleep with
us which then creates this whole cycle
now usually when I have that sleep like
this I tend to spiral down because I
start worrying about sleep it just
results in a few days of bad sleep until
my body gets so exhausted that it just
gets knocked out and here's the good
news about this Devil's cycle when I'm
in that downward spiral I'm in a dark
place so I'm stressed it all starts with
exercise I get my blood pumping I get
into my body and that slows down that
downward spiral then I sleep a little
better which makes it easier to eat
healthy then I have more willpower to go
to bed on time then I sleep better then
I have more energy to work out and that
downward spiral slowly becomes an upward
spiral you look tired yeah 65. do you
feel like you're actually in a place to
like
get to the root of this
yes I've I've really had enough so when
I'm working with people I always start
at the root looking at when did these
sleep problems develop so it doesn't
matter how many tools and techniques and
strategies and gadgets and gizmos and
all the things that you have your
behavioral patterns are all tied to your
identity and your belief systems
yeah what I'm looking for is really an
identity shift and I've just been
telling everyone like Oh I'm a terrible
sleeper I just can't sleep I just
there's something wrong with me all we
have to do is show the nervous system
that is actually safe
to sleep and that takes either time and
repetition or heightened emotion and
when you truly feel that it's safe to
sleep eventually you're going to
re-pattern that belief and then
everything's going to change and you're
never going to look back and your sleep
will be different for the rest of your
life damn
am I making a custom hypnosis track for
myself
Maybe
don't judge my subconscious will accept
everything that I'm about to tell it
I easily and effortlessly fall asleep
I'm a deep sleeper who easily adapts to
changing circumstances
[Music]
what a loser is that what high sleep
scores do to you get it out now
so that I don't have to deal with it in
the night otherwise it's that's
suppressed
whoa
don't think I woke up
he ate sleep Squad Kyle oh hey Kyle
88 sleep Squad yeah
oh
how'd you do yeah I checked this morning
it's 88. let's go let's go yeah see this
is much better you going to bed a little
bit earlier I think it's going to be
really big for you but what if I have a
social event do I want to socialize or
do something or if you want to really
have a good sleep my rule I never get
more than two nights of bad sleep in a
row kind of the struggle of being
healthy so many things that you try to
avoid and then you don't really fit in
anymore I mean that's the whole reason
why you should join drbn though right
it's like you know it seriously you can
meet other people like you I mean he's
right this is why this Channel and
driven exists
quick update so far 20 000 of you have
joined the driven 30 Challenge and have
met people from all over the world who
are on the same path which is so
exciting and about that there's going to
be some updates in the coming weeks
dude I have an 88 sleep school it's just
one reference experience now you can
just build on that yes it's like yeah
I'm an 88 sleep guy no big deal exactly
where are you the difference in How I
Feel is just night and day I'll just
feel sharp and a good mood
knowing how I feel now I'm not willing
to go back I've always told myself I've
tried everything and I assume my body
was somehow broken or there's something
wrong with me you know but once I
consistently focus on the basics I slept
well
and if I hear my relationship to sleep
and rest I think I can get into the 90s
and beat Kyle
[Music]
all right check this
oh
oh I told you man hit that 90. I said it
if you focus on this you will beat this
man right here believe it dude yeah you
did it man you're in the 90 club now now
my sleep is still not amazing but I'm on
my way to recovery it is so much better
whatever you're struggling with whether
it's sleep anxiety depression yes you
may have tried everything but have you
tried nailing the basics are you
exercising daily getting enough sunlight
winding down in the evenings do you have
fulfilling relationships it's pretty
simple but doing it is an entirely
different thing Kyle and I recorded a
podcast with all the details on the
basics so you can nail them as well
there's too much information to cram it
all in here so check it out if you're
interested in that there's a link below
I'll see you over there